[Music]
bill's in san antonio hi bill how are
you
hey dave how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
man i'm so excited to talk to you um
so i'm 31 been married two years my wife
and i have about 45 000 in student loan
debt
right now that's all we've got
i work for my family in agriculture
farming and ranching
and
i make about 30 000 a year my wife makes
about 40. so
um recently we've been hammering down on
the debt getting it paid off we got 25
000 down
got 45 to go
this house has come up it's owned by my
parents they want to sell it to us we
want to buy it we need it
um but you know we're trying to pay the
debt off
so i went to my folks i asked for a
raise i've been with them five years now
never had a pay raise in that time
and they said well why don't you just
let us pay off your your student loan
debt and i said man
i really i mean that's a wonderful
gesture and i appreciate it
but you know we've been working really
hard to pay this off and i feel like if
i take this money they're gonna maybe
there's gonna be some strings attached
and of course that's just based on our
relationship and that's a different
conversation
no it's not it's the same one it's the
exact same one bill
right okay there are no strings yes you
take the gift where there are strings
then we have to discuss the strings
how old are you man 31 31
how do they justify
i'm gonna play it put it on them i'll
put on you
you're 31 years old making 30 000 a year
what are you doing
i work for the family business no we
understand i know that what do you do
physically why are you talking are you
doing this you work too hard you're too
smart you're you you're working it's too
small two or three times that or four
yes i should i also have a business
degree from ole miss um
so
the reason why i do what i do is because
i love it
i'm not working for our parents because
i've got no other way
we raise cattle we raise sheep this is
my passion
i love my job and
i hope to someday have my own place and
this to me is the best way to get there
my own place to run my own business is
what i mean
how is 30 thousand dollars a year
getting you there
well it's very it's slow
it's not it's not man
so um
uh what do they make
oh
gosh i don't know
um you have a business right yes you do
yeah you know
i would say over a million a year
so i must say this um and it's not gonna
be pretty but i'm getting frustrated
your parents taking advantage of you
this is strange it's not cool
it's disrespectful yeah
y'all sound like my wife it's
disrespectful and what's happening is
it's pitting a relationship if they can
just cut you a 45 000 check to wipe it
it's a power play man
that's a move yeah and you smelled the
move i i
dude
i don't know man
i get wanting to i'm from texas i get
one to have a ranch and run the cattle
those are some of my closest friends in
the world but you can't do that at 30
000 you're never going to earn the money
to buy your own ranch or you're playing
a 30-year long game with a couple of
power brokers that they may give you
their ranch someday it's not worth it
man
it's not worth it go get a job at
mcdonald's and make 30 grand at least
you can deliver pizzas at night and make
another 15 on top
you're killing yourself 30 000 bucks
well you're doing your your day-to-day
work you enjoy doing the day-to-day work
um
but but i i honestly believe you could
manage a ranch for somebody
uh as a you know with their business
degree and with your knowledge of the
actual
uh events that have to occur on the
ranch to win
i mean you know how to handle the cattle
you know how to purchase the cattle sell
the cattle and you know deal with the
issue you know how to do that so you
could work for someone else as a as a
manager and make 100 grand a year
couldn't you
maybe not 100 but i think i could double
my income but i'd have to move somewhere
yeah yeah yeah you would so my point is
if your parents hired someone to do what
you're doing they would have to pay them
more than they pay you
oh absolutely okay and
business is this my kids work for me
okay
is they get paid what other people doing
the job that they are doing get paid
not more because they're family and not
less because they're family
and so
rachel cruz is a ramsey personality and
rachel gets paid the same percentages
on a book royalty that dr john deloney
gets paid as a ramsey personality
now she might sell more books or less
books and so she might make more or less
than he makes but not percentage she's
on the exact same comp schedule as ken
coleman as george campbell as dr john
deloney and so that's rachel and so
rachel's not being mistreated by me uh
working here making less because she's
family
and she's also not uh getting paid more
because she's here
working as family
and she does stand to inherit this place
okay yes sir so she so she doesn't have
to accept 30 000 a year instead she
makes what uh you know what these other
guys make doing this thing here that
we're doing so and same is true my son
daniel who's one of our senior vice
presidents and runs runs entre
leadership okay and uh so what does he
make same thing as the other senior vice
presidents that are running business
units as a percentage of their revenues
and how they all get paid and so
you should be paid what someone else
that didn't didn't belong to your family
would be paid but not necessarily more
and so no i do not want the 45 000 and
yes i have to rethink whether i can stay
here at all
right well that's pretty much what i was
thinking dave
thank you yeah i'm sorry
and and and here's the thing
if mom and dad were making
no profit
and you were joining in on the family
business trying to get the thing turned
around and putting your shoulder to the
wheel totally different that's a
different game
but they're they're probably making a
million dollars a year
well i mean i know what they make
because i know what their livestock is
worth
hello
and uh
and so you know and you're not you know
you're not coming in and asking for more
than market rate
but i'm no longer willing to accept less
than market rate
and of the promise of this inheritance
is not enough to keep me
absolutely not
because it's a bad arrangement in the
short term and that that arrangement
comes with strings yeah of all kinds
yeah and that's um so it probably would
be um
good for your mom and dad
relationship with you good for your
relationship with you good for your your
wife's relationship for you for you to
work on another ranch for a while
yeah you don't have to cut strings you
want to burn bridge you have to cut
strings but you like to burn bridges
yeah and just get you get your get your
marketplace savvy established
your value in the marketplace
established and then we can discuss
maybe in two or three years how to come
back
and under what circumstances you can
come back
and it's going to be market rate then
with a plan towards succession in the
business that's laid out guys yeah you
all recommend that i
have this conversation again with them
now that i've listened to you and i'm
probably a little bit more confident
um i mean obviously you guys don't know
them from adam but yeah i mean is it
worth another word yeah it doesn't hurt
yeah it doesn't hurt anything i think
you tell them i'm going to start i'm
going to reach out to seek this this
amount of money this is what my time and
my experience and my knowledge and my
value is and i want to put you all on
notice i'm going to be looking for this
type of work across the across the
southeast region right southwestern
southwestern yeah wherever you happen to
be yeah but the uh yeah i i um but i i
you know
it would
if you want to stay there and they
suddenly want to clean this thing up
then that'd be okay
but
i i'll be honest with you i i think if
they were going to do that they would
already done it right
and my experience has been kids who grow
up in this type of relationship um
undervalue themselves because they've
been undervalued and your wife you
mentioned it she sees it she knows what
her husband's working she's not just mad
at your mom no i want you to see what
you're worth my brother yeah